alors maintenant attention c'est
certainement le plus grand hyatt à n'en
pas douter c'est l'aîné oulala qu'il est
grand holguin écran ou qu'il est grand
c'est eric conquis les grands eric
on applaudit eric
qu'elle a su à eric c'est quand combien
fait quand on peint 10 dont 5 ans ou
assez facile étonnant alors qu'est-ce
que tu es grand pour cinq ans je vais
voir ton papa s'il est aussi grand où il
est après ils démonteront papa est plus
petit toit tourner les tout petits il
est très grand combien il mesure 5
mètres
c'est un monsieur vous devez avoir du
mal à vous habiller en confection ton
papa mesure 5 mètres et dammam en
cimaises des viatiques moins chère
madame
voilà une grande famille lors du bourget
et tu as un frère tu es tu n'as pas de
frère pas de soeur vous êtes une grande
fille tué un chien les combinés mesure
est ce que c'est la première fois que tu
rencontres nana mouskouri et que tu la
vois pour de vrai et à ton avis combien
ils mesurent sans fin